LeBron breaks the scoring record I mean
this is just sustained Elite play
and then sustained health I think that's
the most impressive thing about this
it's like same thing with Brady it's
like you have to give someone credit for
staying healthy yeah like that's not
luck
they are stretching they're eating right
they're doing all the things we see them
in the gym honest stories almost every
day yeah and you see them doing those
stupid bands and you're like what the
[__] he's doing those bands yeah so that
he can play yeah 82 games a year yeah
and eating right and filling your body
with good [__] and not getting [__]
drunk and like going clubs which is why
the cream shit's so impressive yeah
Kareem was doing that in [__]
Converse like that's all first but look
at Kareem he went four years of college
at UCLA playing at 42 when Larry Bird's
done in 34-35 mid 30s yep so you look
LeBron was in the league from 19. he's
still going of course but yeah it just
shows what Kareem did without the yeah
it's a bit a bit more impressive well
I'm gonna give a little pushback so
Kareem stopped at 42.
LeBron is 38.
that's four more years yeah now LeBron
didn't play four years in college he
came to the NBA immediately yeah that
evens out
he was in a different time where they
probably weren't he didn't have a
nutritionist to [__] this one
he's a medical Marvel in a lot of ways
because like he started doing different
things like he would start doing martial
arts yeah so he was doing like yoga he
was doing different things to like
extend the length of his body it looks
like LeBron played less games like 140
less games than Kareem wow wow according
to this GP his games played he played
100 or 1400 Karima Julia Clark played 15
tomorrow wasn't it Kareem ABS was a bar
I just started one time dude my [__]
bad but yeah he played 100 extra games
yeah I mean I listen say whatever you
want about LeBron man you see him drop
the F-bomb
yeah that's so funny every channel cuts
to him everyone's in the thing they cut
to him ESPN TNT all of them and they're
it's the it's the middle of the game
they just stopped the game for him to
talk yeah and they go you broke the
record he gives him the ball he gives
this whole speech and then he goes man
[__] it thank y'all and it just drops
across every Network you're live just so
you know nice that's so good people you
know he'd been wanting to do that for
him yeah look at this ready look at this
way look at games played
Michael Jordan is the fifth all time
right
LeBron is number one with 1410 games
played Kareem Abdul-Jabbar is number two
with 1560 games played Carl Malone is
number three with
1476 games played Kobe Bryant is number
four with 1346 game played Michael
Jordan is number five with 1072 games
played yeah now keep in mind he retired
uh for uh he's trying a couple times
yeah but in his Peak he retired but to
score that many points he's the ultimate
score it's in the top 10 he's scored the
second least only Will Chamberlain
played fewer games and scored as many
points to be in the top ten in that
[__] crazy Jordan's ultimate score
yeah that's the thing it's like LeBron
is not the greatest score of all time
yeah no Jordan is the greatest score of
all time I wouldn't even say LeBron's
second Kobe's probably second yeah you
can make that argument for sure I just
think people are trying to go up well
he's the greatest scorer of all time
he's like no no he's not no no no he's
like the best averages like he is like
the healthiest over time he's able to
like perform at a high level for the
longest amount of time so like he might
not be the fastest Sprinter but he's
like the best marathon runner yes you
know what I mean which is its own credit
yeah I just want to take away from
LeBron I think it's so easy to kind of
do in these moments like what this
achievement is longevity is that's what
you're saying yeah exactly and I think
that yeah I think that you need to
celebrate that because right now guys
break down quicker yeah when there's is
all the steroids and all these things
you could be pumping your body full like
the tendons can't help it like wasn't
there like um
didn't didn't somebody do this like a
study about how like there's way more
ATL sprains now than there ever has been
in like football sort of kind of
remember this but I I can't recall
anything but I think it is because guys
are pushing their physical limits but
the knee joint itself is the same right
yeah it can't evolve at the same speed
right yeah you can you can strengthen
the muscles around the knee to take the
pressure off of it but like
if you're weighing two [__] 60 or 280
whatever the hell LeBron weighs and
you're putting that foot down and
putting all 260 on it to change
direction yeah
and you threw that 82 games a year for
[__] 20 years that's insane yeah
yeah so that's where I'm like in most
insane athlete like physical specimen
like that's crazy to put your body
through that much wear and tear for that
long yes that's impressive yes like
being healthy is impressive in itself
and performing at the highest level yeah
to drop 28 a game last season at 30s 70s
probably or something like that and when
he was going through that little slump I
was like ah finally we're finally
starting to see him Decline and then
both now he's [__] cooking right now
like these averages are crazy have you
ever heard the fun average thing he
averaged 27 7 and 7 his whole career but
he's never scored 27-7 in all the games
but it's like I don't know with with
it's so funny to like juxtapose him with
like um Anthony Davis
who can't stay healthy he's constantly
injured constantly breaking down like I
wonder what that's like emotionally for
Anthony Davis to look at a guy like
LeBron who's going out there dropping 28
every night the guy's Invincible maybe
has rolled his ankle once in 20 years
crazy and then just looking at his
inability to stay healthy for a season
yeah like what do you start if you blame
yourself I wonder how much of it you can
just be like oops bad luck or how much
of it is like oh no I don't really
stretch three times a day all right guys
we take a break for a second because I
gotta tell y'all about the best Bonks in
the business man the freeze pipe right
here okay let that smoke hit your lungs
nice and chilly why is it chilly because
they got these glycerin Chambers you
just stuff this in the freezer for a
little bit okay it's gonna come out
you're gonna take tokes that are gonna
be icy cold the biggest rips in the
business the best looking piece you've
ever seen this is class right here
honestly this is class it wants one of
them dirty ratty bongs over there girl
doesn't even want to put her lips up to
it looks absolutely disgusting this has
been your freezer you're popping this
out she don't even know what's going on
this looks like a beaker maybe some sort
of science experiment you look like a
chemist then you pop this part out she's
like oh he's not a chemist
he's just out here trying to take the
best rips in a business is he and he's
going to bestow them upon me as well
maybe some other things later that night
the point is
the smoothest glass pieces at everyday
great prices go to thefreeze pipe.com
and use the code flagrant for 15 off
your water that's thefreeze pipe.com use
the code flagrant for 15 off shop today
you're throwing lungs well thank you now
let's get back to the show The Sleep is
the recovery they asked LeBron something
interesting in a uh in an interview now
LeBron be lying his [__] ass off and
everything but they asked them they go
uh what was your sleep like last night
and he goes I want to sleep around like
12 I woke up at eight I ate breakfast I
went back to sleep at 8 30 I woke up
again at 12 30. oh wow that's 12 hours
of sleep that's a lot
fire that's focused
wow
yeah that's intentional you got to be
like yeah I'm getting my recovery I need
to do a sleep study because I've been
wearing a [__] watch and it's saying
that I'm not getting like
yeah
and I snore a lot and so I think that oh
you could have like a little apple yeah
I think so have you tried like the mouth
tape yet no what's that you just put
tape on your mouth so the goal is for
people to breathe breathe out of there
just out of their nose it's gonna help
like also your mouth Health gum disease
I do that [__] I just don't want to die
[Music]
this is Anthony Davis went after LeBron
scores uh like the career high whatever
this is Anthony Davis reaction
[Applause]
where is he he just sat down right he
sat down LeBron puts the shot up
oh wow they ain't getting along
that's very interesting they ain't
getting along I mean God the whole team
is just everyone in the stadium knew
what was happening you can't be like oh
maybe he wasn't aware every human being
in La at that moment everyone in that
Stadium knew what was going on
and he just became but even if you don't
like the guy you're like oh I just
witnessed history enough yeah yeah
Witnesses it wasn't funny how they just
like
they stopped the game all together
it was the middle of the games like
usually I thought they would play it out
and then they would do the whole time
out but they did the ceremony before
they yeah yeah
and then they played a minute of the
third and then the fourth started I
don't know why you keep playing after
that that'd be like so embarrassed I'd
be like like bad people coming on the
record he's giving this speech and then
they had to go back and play yeah that
is honestly fire be like yo the game's
not as important as you giving a little
speech right now that's funny bro so
he's like out of breath they're like
well I want to thank my mom and just
like it's crazy and then goes back to
playing yeah that's so weird that's fun
I've never seen that before really a
fire that's better
it is better because it's not you know
all the momentum goes away but it is
also very unique that you would stop a
game for a celebration yeah like they
would never allow you to have an extra
time out they never allowed you to do
anything to affect the momentum and like
how about the other team like yeah what
if that was a huge advantage to the
Lakers yeah you know stop a run they
were on it is a funny acknowledgment
that like all these rules were made up
oh yeah you know what I mean but the
purity of the sport is like no no
there's something cool we'll stop it no
one gets what makes the money yeah
exactly but it's just very funny shout
out to LeBron man you are unique yeah
he's a legend yeah absolutely guys that
was a clip from our exclusive patreon
episode watch the whole episode and many
more we drop a new patreon episode every
single week so make sure you join the
[__] Army at patreon.com flagrant
peace